Ready for your next challenge?
Now this one may seem much harder, but
it's not actually as bad as it might seem at first.
Right now if you click on one of these, nothing happens.
But if you double click on it, it'll actually put you into edit mode.
I can type again, and press enter.
And sure enough, it just changed the to do application item.
But that's not very intuitive, so
let's add an edit button that shows up next to the delete button.
You'll notice when you hover over one of these.
You also get a delete button that pops up.
If i type some nonsense in here, when I press enter sure enough I can
roll over and press the x button and it will go away forever.
Now we want to add an edit button just like this x button here.
Just right next to it instead, so there will be an x button and an edit button.
Now I did a little bit of work for you.
You won't have to write any CSS for this one.
If you make a button with a class of edit-btn,
it'll get all the proper style to appear in just the same way as the x button.
Now you're job is to figure out where to put the button code.
The actual button, physical button.
And how to wire up that button, so when you click on it, it edits the note.
Remember first, be a detective, then be tofu,
when you actually make the changes.
Best of luck.